algo que se les olvidó mencionar en mi
presentación es que soy muy buena para
predecir el futuro
hoy creo que es un buen día
creo que les voy a regalar predicciones
a algunos de ustedes
hay por aquí personas levanten su mano
con el cabello rizado ojos de color
qué y veo por ahí algunos bien veo que
su futuro estará lleno de dificultades
que por esa apariencia que ustedes
tienen
muy difícilmente van a encontrar trabajo
muy difícilmente puedan encontrar una
oportunidad de llegar a ser
independientes tendrán una vida muy
difícil
hay personas con personas que escriben
con la mano izquierda personas sordas
ok
y lamento informarles pero escribir con
la mano izquierda no es normal la
mayoría de nosotros lo hacemos con la
mano derecha
creo que para usted es lo mejor va a ser
que los mandemos una escuela especial
para que resumen reciban la educación
especial y entrenarlos a que vayan
escribiendo con la mano derecha pero si
no lo logran los vamos a catalogar
siempre como personas especiales
levante la mano a quien le parecieron
estas predicciones basadas en la
apariencia injustas
creo que la mayoría
y sin embargo es algo que todos los días
hacemos con las personas con
discapacidad intelectual todos los días
nos atrevemos a juzgar a predecir su
futuro solamente por la apariencia por
tener ojos rasgados por tener alguna
discapacidad nos atrevemos a decir que
tendrán dificultades que siempre van a
ser se van a ser dependientes que
siempre van a estar desempleados no les
damos oportunidades no tenemos ningún
tipo de flexibilidad con ellos
sin embargo las personas con
discapacidad intelectual si pueden
llegar a ser miembros activos de la
sociedad
yo no era consciente de esto creo que
como la mayoría cuando no tenemos a una
persona con discapacidad en nuestra
familia o en nuestro círculo inmediato
pues nosotros no somos conscientes todo
esto cambió en el 2010 cuando nació
melanie mi primer sobrina
melanie nació con síndrome de dawn
fue
pues un golpe muy duro para la familia
tenemos muchos prejuicios tenemos mucho
miedo mucho mucha inquietud sobre su
futuro de la calidad de vida lo que
llegar a poder hacer
con el paso del tiempo melanie fue
creciendo fue desarrollando se fue
aprendiendo nos llenó de amor en la casa
y éramos súper felices cuando veíamos
que melanie aprende una nueva palabra
aprendió 'número aprendió un color
disfrutábamos cada pequeño logro con
ella
nunca voy a olvidar que un día fuimos a
un restaurante de comida rápida llegamos
y para nuestra sorpresa estaba un chico
con síndrome de down con su uniforme
super limpio bien pues estoy con
muchísimas ganas de trabajar
obviamente me quedé viendo normal este
lo estuve observando mucho rato y
después me di cuenta que lo único que le
estaba haciendo
era limpiar mesas
y no es que limpiar mesas esté mal
pero cuando él intentaba tener
iniciativa para hacer algo más
inmediatamente lo regresaban a limpiar
mesas acaso era por su condición era por
su síndrome de dawn
me fui a mi casa con todas esas dudas
con ese sentimiento y estaba súper feliz
que el chavo estaba trabajando de ver lo
que tenía un empleo pero me dio mucha
tristeza el imaginar o el pensar que no
importará cuánto melanie pudiera llegar
a aprender ella probablemente solo iba a
estar destinada a hacer un empleo
sencillo o estar desempleada o no hacer
algo que ella le gustara porque por su
condición no le iban a dar la
oportunidad
llegué a mi casa me puse a investigar y
descubrí algo que me alarmó demasiado me
da mucha mucha inquietud
y es que en méxico solamente una de cada
diez personas con discapacidad
intelectual tiene un empleo eso
significa que el 90 por ciento de las
personas con discapacidad por la misma
condición de melanie están desempleadas
se imaginarán fue algo que me impactó
me marco muy fuerte por esa razón decidí
a través de un emprendimiento social
llamado amor 21 poner mi granito de
arena para poder ir mejorando la
condición de vida de las personas con la
misma condición de e-mail
amor 21 cómo se llama mi proyecto llego
a mi cabeza
así de repente un día en mi casa
acostada en un sillón
llegó
no lo puedes sacar de ahí
y amor 21 era el nombre perfecto amor
por ellos amor por la causa y el 21
haciendo haciendo alusión a la trisomía
la trisomía 21 es cuando en el par 21 de
cromosomas se genera un cromosoma extra
y esa mutación es lo que causa el
síndrome de dawn
entonces ya tenía el nombre perfecto
tenía todas las ganas pero obviamente
tenía muchísimo miedo miedo a lo
desconocido miedo algo nuevo
pero sabía que tenía que hacerlo
entonces pues rápido conseguí donaciones
de maderas de muebles hablé a todos mis
amigos mi familia entre todos fuimos
recortando pegando armando le fuimos
dando forma y finalmente lo logramos
de hecho
en seis días se cumple un año de que
hicimos realidad ese sueño
ese sueño en el que creamos una
cafetería en la que chicos con síndrome
de dawn chicos con autismo realizan el
90% de las actividades ellos sirven a la
clientela ellos se encargan de recibirla
se encargan de
y preparar los alimentos preparar las
bebidas preparan todo lo que lo que el
cliente desea
y ha sido una satisfacción muy grande el
ver este proyecto porque esas personas
generalmente son apartadas generalmente
son vistas como angelitos como niños
eternos y con este proyecto vamos
demostrando que ellos si pueden trabajar
que están listos para mostrar sus
habilidades desarrollar su talento en un
trabajo que ellos disfrutan
muchos lo han dicho y lo piensan
que trabajar con personas con
discapacidad intelectual puede ser muy
difícil
o que sería imposible hacer que ellos
memoricen un proceso completo
pero en realidad no en realidad a veces
solo falta un poco de paciencia un poco
una oportunidad un poco de flexibilidad
o algo aún más sencillo un pequeño
ajuste en el modo en el que nosotros los
estamos enseñando
para que con eso ellos tengan la
confianza y logren el aprendizaje que
nosotros estamos buscando
cuando george entro a la cafetería
él jamás había trabajado
era su primer empleo lo fuimos
conociendo
y nos fuimos dando cuenta qué es lo que
le interesaba mucho eran las bebidas
pero goerges tenía un problema george no
sabe leer
ni identificar las letras
entonces obviamente era muy difícil para
él el identificar los ingredientes las
etiquetas para poder crear una bebida
basto solamente quitar las etiquetas
viejas
y poner fotos de fresa de galleta de
café para que el visualmente pudiera
identificarlos y con eso crear una
bebida perfecta
actualmente george
es un experto en frases y bebidas
calientes el sabe preparar de manera
autónoma 11 12 18 bebidas
y no nada más eso sabe hacer sándwiches
chilaquiles molletes de todo y qué va a
pasar con este aprendizaje que le está
teniendo
que el día de mañana
si george lo quisiera podría emprender
de manera personal podría asegurar un
ingreso con este oficio que él ya tiene
actualmente
otro caso que me sorprendió muchísimo ha
sido el de david
david fue diagnosticado con síndrome de
asperger
y pese a cualquier diagnóstico negativo
él decidió salir adelante decidió
desarrollar su potencial
y aprender
actualmente david es un pero profesional
él sabe cómo hacer desde la masa la
forma de las crepas decorarla todo
justamente antes de empezar la plática
estaba viendo la cámara
david ahora ya sabe hacer de dos en dos
crepas el ya está avanzando innovando en
su oficio cuando en un inicio se le dijo
que no podía en un inicio se le dijo que
él no podía trabajar
también ha desarrollado un liderazgo con
sus compañeros un liderazgo en el que es
capaz de dirigir un servicio asignando
tareas a sus compañeros y asignada pues
las responsabilidades de sus compañeros
y verifica la calidad de lo que se está
entregando a los clientes
y me puedo pasar todo el día platicando
les contándoles las maravillosas
habilidades que ellos tienen que
generalmente no son valoradas en las
organizaciones y que quizás deberíamos
de aprovecharlas
tal es el caso de gerardo
gerardo tiene la memoria
extraordinario que he visto
gerardo es capaz de memorizar un manual
de operaciones completo palabra por
palabra es capaz de memorizar todos los
gramos
no sólo eso en la cafetería
gerardo es capaz de memorizar se los
nombres de todos los clientes que están
en el comedor
y eso pienso que es una habilidad
maravillosa porque quiere decir que
gerardo puede dar un servicio
personalizado por esa extraordinaria
memoria que tiene pero qué pasa en
muchas ocasiones por el hecho de decir
tienes autismo los bloqueamos nos
enfocamos en lo que no pueden hacer o en
lo que pensamos que no pueden hacer en
lugar de darles una oportunidad pero
ellos están listos para salir al mundo
para demostrar que pueden lograrlo
ha sido realmente este ya casi un año de
trabajo con los chicos
ha sido muy benéfico para mí porque he
aprendido muchas lecciones de vida
hoy me gustaría compartirles y que si
ustedes se identifican las pudieran
hacer propias
la primera
es que
cuando uno puede cumplir un sueño
hacerlo realidad
es algo maravilloso es algo tan
satisfactorio
pero que ese sueño
ayude a los demás a crear los suyos o
ayuda a inspirar a otras personas
realmente es algo que no tiene nombre
porque el apoyar las grandes causas
siempre te va a traer beneficios y no
nada más personales también
profesionales porque porque puedes
conectar tu carrera profesional con tu
propósito de vida en mi caso mi trabajo
actual como maestra mis estudios se
fusionaron con este amor con esa empatía
hacia melanie para poder crear este
proyecto y eso me ha hecho una persona
más satisfecha más plena
además
que siempre vas a tener una motivación
constante cuando apoya es una buena
causa una motivación porque tú sabes el
porqué lo estás haciendo y en esos
momentos de altibajos de malos momentos
vas a recordar ese por qué y te vas a
levantar y continuar adelante
además un beneficio invaluable es el
tener en tus manos el poder para cambiar
el mundo hacerlo un mejor lugar para
vivir
ellas me llamen
ella tiene 10 años
tiene muchos sueños muchas esperanzas
ganas de salir adelante
hoy tú y yo sabemos que ella sí puede
cumplirlos si puede llegar a ser un
miembro activo de la sociedad
si tú y yo
dejamos de verla como un angelito
dejamos de verla como un niño eterno y
empezamos a aceptar sus diferencias
empezamos a ver las diferencias como
algo que nos enriquece no algo que nos
limita
levanta tu mano
si te encantaría que predijera mos en
base a tu apariencia tu futuro un futuro
poco alentador un futuro lleno de
dificultades levanta tu mano
creo que ninguno
ve en busca de tus sueños
persigue tus metas no te olvides que
quizás en ese camino te vas a encontrar
con personas con diferencias a ti
diferentes habilidades diferentes
capacidades pero en ese momento vas a
tener la oportunidad perfecta en tus
manos de poder integrarlos de poder
crear un cambio en la sociedad que tanto
lo necesitamos
es momento de olvidarnos de predecir el
futuro de otros
[Aplausos]